good afternoon everybody
thanks for uh fighting the power and
coming to the go talk and not going to
the java talk
um so my name is richard crowley and uh
i'm really excited to be at strangeloo
because i went to washu and i love
coming back to st louis
so this is i think one of the best
conferences there is right now i'm very
excited to be a part of it
i work for a company called bettable
it's gambling as a service
no kidding we do the money we do the
math
we make it so any old game developer can
build legal gambling apps themselves
get into the market and compete in a way
that they couldn't before
it's fantastic fun i'm here to talk
about scalability
and because this is mostly about
programming and how we build services in
a particular language a lot of the
points of scalability are actually about
how it scales to a development team to
more
engineers to more features and then only
sort of tangentially to
how it scales to many systems as you get
bigger and bigger that latter becomes a
lot more important and so there are
avenues where i feel like go sets you up
to succeed in that regard but we're
going to
spend time talking about both of them
today
so this is going to be audience
participation time
raise your hand if you've written at
least one go program
fantastic raise your hand if you have go
in production
also fantastic one guy's shaking his
hand
used to let's talk later
who has only go in production i can't
claim that that's the case for myself
either but i'd love to get there
uh who thinks goes a little too
mainstream now
yeah okay hipsters
so there's a lot of good reasons to
choose any programming language and
there i feel like i wanted to call out a
few of the good reasons to choose go
one of them is the the brevity in how
you can express yourself
i shouldn't say more about that one is
the static type system and that's a
religious argument and so i'm not going
to say more about that either
or i'll lose my whole time but it gives
you a lot of interesting properties and
and the ability to reason about the
correctness and the safety of your
program and that's very important
another is that it compiles to x86 or to
arm into whatever
which makes it easy to ship which to
some approximation makes it easy to make
a performance system
and then there's this uh this
communicating sequential processes
primitive that's baked into the language
and rich hickey talked about it at
length yesterday i'm going to talk about
it a little bit today
it's a fantastic feature and though it
may be one of the like really shiny ones
it's also
one of the parts that makes go really
special and then there's the the people
behind it ken thompson
you know of unix rob pike and russ cox
that worked on plan nine at bell labs
one of the
would-be evolutions of unix robert
grissomer who worked on hotspot and v8
serious
technical power that i would really like
to stand on the shoulders of
and then there's brad fitz who's i put
in a different category because he does
a different thing
he does this one really annoying thing
where he solves the hard problem before
i get to it so that i can use his code
and it's no fun but it means that the
standard library
in that goes ships with is getting a ton
of love and it's getting better
all the time and it's becoming one of
the real competitive advantages for the
language
so the fact that he's working on it and
making that happen is a huge plus
but there's also bad reasons to choose
go and i'm totally guilty of this
not for the stuff that we have in
production i feel like we did our
homework there
but it's not java and it doesn't run on
the jvm and
thanks for fighting the
uh it's power a bad reason to choose go
if you look
deeper i feel like the thing the real
problems that people have with
java come out and and when you evaluate
them
on their merits and not on the the
religious and superficial reasons a lot
of times go will come out on top and a
lot of times it won't
so a couple ways that it won't is if for
some reason the problem that you're
working on won't tolerate
a more naive garbage collector perhaps
you just can't help but create a lot of
garbage
that's a thing and that's possible and
if so maybe
maybe you choose not to use go perhaps
you have some weird legacy dependency
that
you would have to do the work to
integrate with that system
if you were to use go and you don't have
the bandwidth on your team that's also a
valid reason
if though that's an open source thing i
would hope that you kind of pay it
forward and do the work to open source
that
anyway the spoiler is that we've chosen
go because i'm here to talk about go
and rule number one of go is that you
always always always google
golang or you're gonna have a bad time
never google for go you're gonna get
stuff about games you're gonna get
driving directions it's
not fun so now some code
um is this legible enough back there or
should i bump it up one
no news is good news all right so we're
gonna skip hello world and do hello dub
dub dub and the interesting parts of
this
are how short it actually is so beyond
just
the structure of being a go program
we've got a function in the middle here
with a curious
signature it takes a response writer and
a request
that's all i'll say right now i'm just
pointing out that it's there but we're
using some global magic here to set up a
handler for slash
and then serve port 8080. that's that's
all this does and it'll serve hello www
all day long
so we've got a function and it has a
particular signature and in fact
in go you can much like a normal
language take any number of parameters
but you can also
return any number of parameters and this
is
both as a way out of a couple of other
design
features and also an awesome feature all
on its own
every sort of functions of closure if
you squint at it just right and
otherwise they're pretty unsurprising so
this bit about
multiple return values i think is
important to call out and to really
make the the framing around it right
conventionally the last of your return
values or the only of your return values
is an error and that's a global
type in the language it's an interface
that you can implement
and this is what you use instead of
exceptions there are no exceptions in go
and this is on purpose and it's it's
meant to
force an attitude adjustment errors are
not exceptional cases
errors are just something that happened
and a nil error is an indication that
something happened
just the same as a as an e-perm error
using the air as an opportunity to
communicate what that was that happened
to the caller is an important
responsibility of the implementer of a
function and that
having it be an error rather than
exception forces the caller to deal with
it and to
understand the consequences of what
they've done so this
i feel like it's a feature and maybe i'm
twisted maybe i've had too much kool-aid
but that's the pitch for the no
exceptions thing and go should you be
curious
so moving back into the language there's
also structs i want to go through a
couple of the bits of the language very
quickly to set some
some baseline here structs only have
data in them so you don't declare
a a struct like you would a class in c
plus plus or java
it's just a bucket of data and
everything has a type and it has order
and it has
structure and memory that you control
which is very important then you can
attach
methods and you can attach meth methods
to absolutely anything you can attach
methods to int
you can attach methods to the empty
struct that takes up
zero bytes in memory think about that
for a minute
and here we've got the same signature on
this method that we had on our function
serve http takes a response writer and a
request just like before and in fact
this
function is exactly the same plus we're
using our receiver
to increment a counter and this
this signature is important to us
because of the next thing the cool
the magic part of go is the interface
which is
akin to a struct which is a bucket of
data an interface is a bucket of method
signatures
it has no data it can't have data it's a
type
that declares a bunch of method
signatures just like one would in java
but the difference is you don't have to
declare that you implement
an interface if you happen to
the compiler will allow you to use your
value
as something that expects that interface
a
parameter to a method or a member of a
struct perhaps
notice the bottom struct there defines a
serve http method with this signature
that we've now seen
four times this is what it means to play
the http game and go and this is the
building block on which we've
built all of the things that we use to
build web services at bettable
so we're going to rewrite now our http
example
and we're going to not use the the goofy
fast path global stuff we're going to
build it ourselves so we understand the
pieces that are involved
so the top two lines we're creating this
thing called a servmux this is a router
it takes url patterns and turns them
into a handler that it can call that
serve http method on
we're registering the handler we defined
a couple slides ago that
the one that had the method that was the
real first class kind of thing
and then we're creating a server with
that handler
now this servmux thing is itself a
handler that dispatches to other
handlers so we're starting to see how
the turtles are stacking up right
then we're going to decompose the listen
and serve that we had before
into a listener and the serve method
and that's relatively unsurprising we're
going to do that to lead ourselves into
the next couple of examples
but the important thing about this this
is the same
program as we had before logically it's
decomposed into its parts so that we can
get at them and change them a little bit
now another bit of audience
participation who's been burned by base
http server or web brick or something
like that some crap
standard library server there's some
some honest people here the rest of you
are kidding yourselves
everybody's been burned by this it
doesn't behave like a real web server it
isn't a real web server
so we're right to be suspicious of what
goes standard library web server does
so we're going to figure out what it
does by way of an analogy
we're going to strip away the http stuff
and we're going to build an echo server
so carrying from the last slide where we
had the the raw
net.listen call that builds a listening
socket
on our network we have that same idea
here listen on port one two three four
and then we enter a loop and then go the
for loop with no
anything just for ever so we're going to
loop forever
and we're going to accept on our
listener this is pretty normal right you
call the accept system call you get back
a socket in this case we get a
connection a little bit more hydrated
object
and then we go handle con it reads like
english
this go keyword in the language takes
any function call that you can
possibly write and it spawns what's
called a go routine a new go routine
and it runs that function there there's
two interesting things
one you can never ever know for sure
just as this is whether that go routine
is running or
has run or has not run or has died or
errored
there's no inherent return value from
that
the other is that because it's this is
not spawning a thread
we get to take advantage of a lot of
real nice properties
so in this go routine in this off to the
side asynchronous thing
we have another function and there's a
couple of quick things
at the top we use the defer feature of
the language which is really sweet
it's kind of a finally sort of setup
where conduct close is going to be
called at the end of the function
no matter what no matter how it returns
and then we create a buffer for
ourselves for for our echo server and
then we go into another forever sort of
loop where we read and then write and
then read and then write
all day long that's it that's an echo
server
now this is really nice because all
we're really
expressing here with the exception of
allocating a buffer is exactly the
the logic that we want to happen we want
to read and then we want to write
exactly that same thing out
no callbacks no state machines no no
nonsense
this go routine per connection pattern
smells fishy though right
it smells like uh apache max worker or
something or others
and it seems like something we should
cap
and in reality the runtime is doing that
capping
for us there's an environment variable
called gomax procs that will limit the
number of actually running p threads if
you're on linux
and multiplex your million go routines
onto those
eight p threads or whatever you would
decide to run
and so this this coupled with the fact
that they the stacks of these
go routines are segmented so there's
their low memory footprint means you can
actually run
many many thousands of them at a time
and proof's in the pudding
this is how the standard library http
server that powers all downloads at
google
actually works now
this is the first part of what richiki
spent a lot of time talking about
yesterday and i'm going to
mimic a little bit of that is this
communicating sequential processes
research i guess you'd say that
underlies a lot of this so the go
routines are the sequential processes
and this stuff was set out in in
beginning in 1978 by tony hore
and the the go authors summarized it
relatively nicely in the
the effective go article which is a
great read they say do not
communicate by sharing memory instead
share memory by communicating
and this is where we need the
communicating part of this to come
together so that we have the tools
available to us to do
both this you know wide fan out sort of
connection handling stuff as well as
isolation of critical sections
and connection pooling and things like
that so
we've had the go routines they're called
parallel commands in the research if you
look deeper into it and now for channels
the this is the communicating part
and these are called input output
commands in the research if you go look
so the top two lines of code there
declare
two channels one of them is
unbuffered and and that means that it is
totally
synchronous when you send there has to
be someone to receive it
the other one is buffered so there's
this sort of immediate
uh immediate cueing plus back pressure
when the queue is full so you
get the nice failure degradation that
you want when your queues are backed up
as rich noted yesterday unbounded queues
are
a recipe for disaster it's asking to
handle that bug
later i did some benchmarking
on this because i was curious how they
stacked up against mutexes and
the truth is because the the semaphore
implementation
within channels is so purpose-built is
so ingrained to it
it's actually really fast to the point
that allocating a channel
and then using it once is fast enough
that you don't
you would want to do that over using a
mutex for a lot of jobs
but and there's a downside here when
you're dealing with an oltp kind of
workflow
workload when you're dealing with web
services the temptation to use these
new exciting hammers the the shiny
features of go is is really there
but i think it's it's worth taking
caution before you jump right in
because you're sacrificing a couple of
things first
you're sacrificing the ability to to
scale out in the small
and i mean in the same sense that you
have another web server over here
that handles the same sort of traffic
but is unrelated
you can have another go routine over
here that handles the same sort of
traffic
but is is unaware of the other guy and
the ability to
buy better hardware that can run four
times as many go routines
is a scalability technique that you
prevent by having too tightly coupled a
system of go routines within one
process the other opportunity to really
shoot yourself in the foot
by relying too heavily on the csp
primitives is that all of those cues
that
may have data in them have to be drained
carefully
otherwise you open yourself up to data
loss opportunities
in a in what's usually a very stateless
transient system
so the sort of poster child for this in
my mind is the
is the thought experiment of how you
gracefully stop a web server
really you just stop listening and then
let everybody finish right that's
easy to some degree and yet if you have
a bunch of cues you need to drain it's a
process that takes a lot of care
so the http package here while it's been
awesome so far
is annoyingly unhelpful and and
partially this is the community's fault
for not being able to
agree on exactly what graceful stop
means
but we can take matters into our own
hands slightly with what i'm calling
clumsy stop so we're adding two things
to our example from before the first is
a channel of signals
which we're going to use to just let the
runtime tell us about sigint and sig
term whenever they happen to show up
and then instead of serving we're going
to go serve our web server over in
another go routine
and that means that we have this main go
routine that we're
executing in to block on the channel and
then we can clean up after ourselves and
the the clumsy part is that the cleanup
is just
close the listener so there'll be no new
connections and then wait for one minute
assuming everybody's going to be done
that quickly
now you can make any sort of clever
system you want
to keep track of your running
connections your your open requests and
shut them down gracefully
and hopefully the standard library will
expose enough of its internals
to let us do that in a very elegant way
soon but for the moment even this is
graceful
the downside is that it's a one minute
outage every time you deploy
but we can do better we can augment that
further
same example but replace the the raw
signal handling with
this go again library that handles the
sort of unix style fork a child let it
inherit the listener and then kill the
parent pattern
and all we need to do to use that is
replace the signal channel with await
signals
and the listening with conditionally
listening or inheriting
and now as long as you use something
that's not upstart or demon tools to
supervise your services
you can gracefully stop while actually
performing a zero downtime restart so
your new process takes over
instantaneously
cool stuff right we still just have a
plain old
web server here and so that's as low
that's as low down to the bottom as i
want to go
i want to start back at our hello dub
dub dub and go higher level now
and talk about uh web frameworks and
building web services and the apis that
we
use day-to-day there's a lot of stuff
going on in the space right now
much of it we have cribbed from
aggressively and so
depending on your exact needs or your
curiosities i
encourage you to check them out gorilla
and revel are very ambitious very
high feature things that i think are
awesome for building full web apps
go rest is interesting but hides so much
information from the compiler and turns
so much into runtime concerns
that it's in my mind tricky to debug and
then there's a lot more things like pat
and sort of the the small pieces that
you can join together
and so let's talk more about this over
beers if you're
interested or curious or if i've left
something off i apologize
but what i really wanted to talk about
is uh is what we've been
doing and we bundled it up in homage to
drop wizard uh under the name tiger
tonic and i was gonna
do like a grand reveal here but internet
so uh
this is already open source as of an
hour ago
and this is a collection of things i
hesitate to even call it a framework
it's a collection of
the the pretty version of what i'm going
to talk about for some of the rest of
the talk
that we use pretty happily about a book
so routing what we used in the in the
example before the the servbox from the
standard library
is busted because it only routes
prefixes so you just you end up with a
tree
of handlers that you have to define
yourself and you have to edit yourself
and it's just a ton of
source code so we define this tri-serv
mux thing
that is aware of http methods is aware
of wild cards
and handles this the the routing and the
treeness of it
internally so you don't have to and that
gives us the opportunity to automate
away responding 404
and 405 and pull all those
wild cards from the middle of the nice
human readable urls
into the parameters where you can get at
them programmatically
then there's json because realistically
to me at least web services mean json
these days so
that would have meant wrapping our
response writer from our handler
in a json encoder and it actually is a
relatively elegant thing because of that
writer
interface in go that everything can kind
of be a writer or be a reader
and you can plug them together but it's
awkward and
it's verbose so we thought we could do
better and we thought
now we think we've done a lot better
because what we have is a different
method function
a different function signature that
takes in a url header and a request and
that request is a real object with a
real
type that you can test and manipulate
as schema almost and likewise there's a
response that you can do the same thing
with and it's
some complete description of the data
you want to take in and the data you
want to take out
and the ugly reflection stuff happens
behind the scenes
and the best part is it all still boils
down to an http handler so you can still
plug it in wherever you want in a
in a larger go http infrastructure
and because we're doing this stuff we
have an opportunity to automate away
some of the common errors
to make using these apis much easier so
the reflection bit
is interesting because well one because
goes reflection package is
awesome so much better than anything
i've ever used in this
area before and so we use it in a couple
of places in this json code that i think
is interesting
so at the top what we're doing is
using reflection to look at the method
that you provided to us grab
the the positional parameter and grab
the type of it
so that we can create an object of the
type that you expect and
deserialize the json into it so that you
get the actual object of the type that
you want and there's no casting and
goofiness going on
and then on the way back out it's sort
of it's easy because you just return
some value and it's easy to take any
value and turn it into json that's
that's the easy side
but that could cause errors to show up
very late in your runtime
process you could have an api that never
gets called for a month
and suddenly explodes because you had a
type error so we
try to move a lot of the control over
what you're putting into the system and
make sure your your signatures are sort
of fuzzy
correct up to the beginning of runtime
in the init functions in the early part
of
registering and building up your service
we also added stuff which this comes up
a thousand times a day i want to handle
this request as long as
you're authorized or the sky's blue or
you're in great britain which is a thing
for us
um so we conditionally handle requests
by building another http handler
that calls a function and if that
function returns a nil error
then we call the real handler and we use
this all the time
[Music]
it's a special case of sort of a
middleware chaining thing which is
less useful honestly than just
conditionally handling requests
and still it's just a handler
now a slight subject change from
the programmer you know in your face
bits of
building web service endpoints
to how we think about our our production
services how we know that they're
functioning correctly how we know that
we're meeting our goals
and these are visibility problems and
there's there's micro and macro
visibility problems and you solve the
micro
problems with logs where you can see
what's going on and you solve
in my opinion the macro problems with
the metrics the numbers the the
aggregates
and uh on the logging front we
we actually use this log thing which
logs full request and response bodies
which is the best thing you can do as
long
as you're careful not to log credit card
numbers there is no debugging tool like
exactly what happened seriously
there's also apache log for people that
don't believe me
um then there's then there's metrics
there's the
the big picture stuff how how healthy
the service is how
how well we're responding how quickly
we're doing so
how shitty our 99 percentile latency is
uh all this stuff is just wrapping up
gometrix which is a port of coda hale's
java metrics which is all very much in
line with what avi bryant was talking
about this morning
with understanding how to properly take
sums of sums and averages of averages
to get meaningful numbers so that you're
not just looking at
junk so we dump all this stuff
on the the outside into a couple of
tools one's called stats knee and one's
called graphite to look at
the last hour and all of time
and have a lot of success with that
there's a lot of other batteries i don't
want to waste all of my or your time
talking about
stuff we open sourced but there's the
sorts of things that we found the need
for
and so they're there i want to take a
step further back now and talk
really about how these web services or
how any web services
work so it's all about being confident
that they do
and before you even start logging or
collecting metrics you test
right and i wanted to call this out
particularly because of the reputation
for statically typed languages to be
tough to test
so it's only four bullet points
you can create request objects very
easily in go and that's
a tribute to the way that the standard
library parses a request and gives it to
you in a digestible manner
it's not a stream of headers that you
have to
on header event stuff it's just an
object so you can fake it
then you can call those serve http
methods because it's handlers all the
way down right
and when you need to give it a response
writer you give it a response recorder
because a response writer is an
interface it turns out
and a response recorder will give you
access to everything that happens so
then
after the fact after serve http returns
you can
assert that the body is what it's
supposed to be that the headers are all
there that the response code's right
or if you're doing the json thing like
we are
100 of the time you can call the
marshalled function directly
and whatever type you put in you put in
and whatever type you get out you'll get
out
and then you can make assertions on that
real type
at a higher level than you know stir
pausing your json because that's that's
error prone
so now we're confident and we're ready
to go to production right uh
and i would say yeah but truthfully uh
no you're not there yet
dependency hell is a real thing even in
brand new languages
i'm sorry to say and the way that go
invites you to install dependencies is
with this go get tool
and it is going to bite you sooner or
later and probably sooner
essentially it always installs master
and so you you have a few options to
deal with that
there are some go specific solutions
which are called go pack and johnny
depps
both of them do roughly the same thing
they
keep a list of the repository urls and
the shas that you want from them
and to me that's that's the same thing
as go
as a git sub module so i say use git sub
module
yeah you have to do one thing after you
clone but it's
it's fine google says vendor third party
code and
they're not wrong but we take a slightly
uh
more humane approach where we vendor
whatever
at the point of continuous integration
whatever past all the tests we vendor
that
so at least we know that everything that
passed test goes with us to staging goes
with us
to production and coupling that with uh
forking all of our third-party
dependencies to our own github means
we're pretty confident that nothing's
getting through without getting tested
so now really we're ready to go to
production and the next question
somebody is going to ask you is well did
you put nginx in front of it or
apache or whatever you want to do and
that's a subtle question for a number of
reasons it depends on a lot of other
things but for
the go web services we're building i say
at this point no
now we're a financial institution
essentially
so we do ssl absolutely everywhere
between everything
all the time the only thing that doesn't
ssl is localhost
and so we do tls termination in tiger
tonic
web apps and that's made very easy by
the go standard library
has a couple of benefits it turns out
there's no crypto step to block your
nginx event loop that's a thing
and there's one fewer hops which at some
marginal level
is going to increase or sorry decrease
your latency
and this tls thing i i put up a code
sample because
uh it's a little bit daunting for
everybody and
uh openssl makes it worse and goes
stuff doesn't make it a lot better but
that's how you create a tls listener and
go
the way that you don't shoot yourself in
the foot with this is to always use the
net.con and net.listener interfaces
and that allows you to
to handle tls connections non-tls
connections
switch it out for openssl later and
there's this baseline of functionality
that
it doesn't matter what kind of listener
you have as long as it can accept
connections and that's that's the level
of thing that we're after here
that's true who said that all right
there are some specific options and the
same is true for unix domain sockets
and the reality there um
well there's i guess a couple things
when you create your
tls listener you can actually create it
from a tcp listener so you can have sort
of a two-step
listener creation process that's how you
would do things like set deadlines on
your listener
man's right though but long before you
get to the
the wastefulness of of goes ssl or
anything like that
it's there's going to be some
inefficiency in your program there's
going to be some scalability problem
in your program i think nothing against
you my programs too and then
the philosophy there is is really to
waste not to
understand when variables you're
allocating
memory that you're allocating gets
promoted to the heap so that it's
eligible for garbage collection
to be conscious of reusing those buffers
so that you're allocating
as little as possible because ultimately
same as in any garbage collected
language the small heap is the fast heap
and you don't get out of this by having
native code you don't get out of this
by rob pike being smarter than you
it's just a reality of life the good
side is that
the fact that you control the memory
layout so
delicately in go means you actually have
an opportunity to
incredibly strongly influence how the
garbage collector perceives what you're
doing
you actually have the opportunity to
create less garbage it's it's a
wonderful thing
we've talked a whole bunch about the the
standard library and building
http handlers and more generally i would
encourage you
to use those those tools to their
fullest effect
to make your deviations small and work
within
the standard library functionality where
absolutely
possible because all the batteries that
come you know around the edges the
network level stuff the tls
stuff the parts of the built-in http
stuff that aren't goofy prefix routers
are good and the more that you can take
advantage of that the faster you're
going to build
more performant more scalable systems
and then
we talked about errors very early on in
the fact that it's your opportunity to
communicate
what went wrong if you're building all
these small handlers that are isolated
and reusable because the you know the
whole point of things like
if is to be able to decouple your
handler from the conditions under which
it's
allowed to be called all these pieces
need to be able to fail fast and they
need to be able to fail in a way that
you can understand what went wrong both
as a developer and programmatically so
that
the error can be propagated correctly
we talked about shared nothing a lot and
the fact that
though we accept in the large that being
able to scale out to
n plus one machines is totally obvious
and not worth
talking about i think it's important to
remember that computers are still
getting
better especially at doing the same
thing in an uncoordinated manner
and plus one times so make sure that as
you build systems you're able to take
advantage of diagonal scaling
when it when the opportunity arises and
that means
that the concurrency primitives should
be used delicately and used purposely
when you have something that truly does
need to be limited in terms of the
number of
in-flight requests and you have a
delicate uh
outside service or api with rate limits
or any number of things
the primitives that go gives you can be
an incredibly expressive way to
model it but you can also artificially
limit the throughput
and the performance and the scalability
of your systems
and then of course we need to measure
everything because flying blind is
by no means a way to build any sort of
service that
performs respectably for users so in the
in the large we talk about counting and
timing things
looking at our logs when they indicate
that there are problems but in the small
there's really cool
tools it hooks into the prof profiler
that you can
call with literally two lines of setup
it's
silly like most of my programs have
command line options to enable cpu
profile
because it adds two lines and an if
statement it's
it's really quite good and then it's all
integrated into the language and it'll
actually fire up a browser
with call graphs in it it's it's slick
so in in total summary if you're
building web services in go i
i encourage you to use handlers to the
absolute greatest degree you possibly
can
and to stick with something that will
allow you to escape off to the side when
you need to do something
different use the concurrency primitives
where you have sort of pipelined things
that that
actually the sort of problem problems
that rich talked about yesterday
are perfect fits for concurrency but i
think generally speaking
oltp workloads are a little bit simpler
and uh and better served by simpler
solutions
so bridge the gap between the the go
routine per connection and the pipeline
sort of designs cautiously and remember
that the error case is not the
exceptional case
in any distributed scalable system
so here's some links to a lot of the
stuff that i talked about so that you
don't have to go googling
johnny depp's surprisingly not going to
turn up a github page
really as of like yesterday
thanks so
if you would uh if you would like to
work on awesome gambling problems and
maybe write some go code
this is how you work at bettable thank
you